[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i'm going to
explain a japanese psychological short
thriller film called chess
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene the world chess
champion akira kato is playing a match
of chess against a computer called the
super blue at the special chess
exhibition while akira's brain can only
calculate three moves in a second super
blue can calculate up to 200 million
moves in a second the chances of akira's
winning seem low but if he loses he will
be the first player in history to lose
to a computer as the intense game
continues he is visibly struggling at
last he drops his king accepting his
defeat the room goes silent and no one
can believe that the world's most
talented chess player who had never lost
a single match just lost to a computer
akira sits with his head down not being
able to process what just happened the
host mocks him as the audience laughs
and reporters click pictures of the
humiliated former grand world champion
akira bangs the chessboard in anger
breaking it in half three years have
passed since the incident after the last
match akira has stopped playing chess
and no one has seen him ever since the
following scene shows us many homeless
people sitting on the side of the road
on a cold morning one of them is akira
who has spent all his money on alcohol
and gambling and is now living on the
streets a fancy car stops by them and
two men in black suits step out of it
they forcefully pick up akira and drive
him away he is taken to a mansion where
he is welcomed by a wealthy old man the
man reveals that he knows who akira is
which is surprising considering he has
changed his name and identity entirely
when akira inquires about who he is the
man says it isn't important he simply
wants to play a game of chess with akira
he reveals a chessboard on the table
which makes akira almost puke he
composes himself and makes an excuse but
the truth is that the thought of chess
makes him sick at this point in his life
he turns away from the chessboard not
being able to look at it akira is the
soros loser in history the old man says
he lost a lot of money betting on
akira's last match since akira doesn't
have even a single penny the man wants
him to play a game to compensate for his
loss akira is unsure about the man's
actual intention but he knows he doesn't
want to do any business with him to get
out of the situation he bluntly tells
the man that he doesn't play chess
anymore moreover he doesn't want to be a
millionaire's plaything the man picks up
the king on akira's side and says that
he has lost without even playing this
reminds akira of his last defeat which
makes him furious
he stops the man and asks him to move
his pawn instead satisfied that he has
finally persuaded akira the old man
plays his move however akira refuses to
turn towards the chessboard or touch the
pieces without even looking he tells the
man to move all of his pieces confident
that he will win the game anyway we
notice that the old man is wearing an
earpiece and talking to someone while
playing akira walks to the window where
he sees a group of men downstairs
wearing white and black clothes and
facing each other the pattern they are
standing in is exactly the same as the
pattern on the chessboard right now as
the old man kills one of the pawns in
the game the man who is in the pawn's
place is stabbed and killed akira
freezes in shock at what he has just
witnessed he asks the man if this is
some kind of joke the man says that the
pawns are mere soldiers so he shouldn't
be sad about one's death akira runs
downstairs to check the dead person for
himself and finds him on the ground
while the other players stand still in
their places he takes the knife out of
the man's body and sees that he is still
alive even on the verge of death the man
smiles and asks sakira what his next
move is after the man takes his last
breath the players around him walk away
leaving akira with a knife and a dead
body in the middle of the street a woman
sees him in the position and assumes
that he killed the person akira freaks
out and retreats stating that it wasn't
him in the following scene he is at his
former doctor saichi tomoda's office the
doctor is surprised to see him after so
many years he and akira's wife kumi keto
have been looking for akira for the past
three years a flashback from three years
ago shows us that after losing the game
with super blue akira had lost the well
to live he used to get nightmares of
chess pieces trying to kill him the
nightmares turned into hallucinations
which made his health even worse he had
always compared his life to a game of
chess and his wife was the queen so when
he lost the match he left his queen
believing he didn't deserve her anymore
akira tells the doctor about the
incident earlier and says he might be in
need of a psychiatrist the doctor
assumes he dreamt of the guy being
killed but akira insists what he saw was
in fact real the doctor asks him to go
home and rest because his mind is still
fragile following that a printer at the
doctor's cabin prints out a paper on its
own the paper says what is your next
move akira realizes that the match of
chess he started that morning is still
going on he shouts that he wants his
pawn moved to the e3 position then the
doctor opens a book to see its pages
have turned into a chessboard the
printer prints another paper that says
in the next move the old man's queen
kills akira's knight
the knight just so happens to be the
doctor to moda he vomits blood and dies
instantly akira is left shocked when he
sees a picture of the doctor riding a
horse on the wall meaning the doctor was
his knight the cup he was drinking from
earlier also has a chessboard pattern so
akira assumes the coffee was drugged a
nurse watches them through the door but
doesn't do anything to save the doctor
she walks in only after he is dead and
asks akira what his next move is akira
runs outside trembling in fear when he
comes across a little kid holding a
drawing with the current format of the
chessboard it is clear that he is also
involved in the game when he asks akira
the same question akira answers that he
wants to move the king to the e2
position the kid tells him that the king
will end up dead making akira run in the
other direction he gets a vision of
people who have died because of the game
and starts hallucinating chess pieces
trying to kill him as he runs away he
reaches a parking lot where the cars
have been parked in the format of the
chessboard unaware of this he gets in
the car that is supposed to be the
bishop and tries to start it however
similar to a bishop in chess the car
only moves diagonally he leaves that car
alone and gets on the one that denotes
the rook the car doesn't start because
it is the opponent's turn to play the
rook from the other side crashes into
his car killing his rook
akira is tripping balls following that
akira goes to his old house only to see
that it is on sale the rook also known
as the castle was actually his house in
real life now that akira gets the hang
of real-life chess he realizes that the
queen is his wife kumi and her life is
in danger as well he goes back to the
old man's home claiming that he wants to
quit playing the game and asks for his
wife however the old man asks akira to
accept his defeat and remove his king to
the end of the game this again reminds
akira of the time he was humiliated
after losing a match with the super blue
he decides screw his wife his pride is
more important with determination he
continues playing the game and asks the
old man to move his king forward the
game goes on for a long time and most of
their pieces are out at last akira is
only two steps away from winning the
game and the old man can do nothing to
save his king however before he can play
his turn two men in suits forcefully
take him away in the following scene the
old man and akira are in a stadium that
has a life-sized chessboard in the
middle the chess pieces are people who
will die with a single wrong move the
old man says that their situation is
similar to an arabian king who used to
play chess with his prisoners killing
them on the spot he states that chess is
a game without emotion because the
players sometimes have to sacrifice
their own pieces in order to win for
akira to win the game he will have to
move a knight to checkmate however if he
does that the old man will kill his
queen akira turns around to see that the
queen is actually his wife kumi who has
been tied up and is held at knifepoint
with tears in her eyes she shakes her
head asking akira to save her
now akira can either win the game or
lose his wife forever he tries to move
from his box to stop the man but a
sniper rifle fires close to his legs as
a warning that moving will get him
killed the old man asks him for the last
time if he wants to sacrifice the queen
or accept his defeat he also adds that a
real champion would think logically and
do what is needed to win the game but
akira tells him to save the queen
without hesitation his wife is more
important to him than winning a match
everyone is shocked at his decision he
moves in front of her and spreads his
hands accepting his defeat the opposing
knight walks towards him with a knife
and stabs him at last akira falls to the
ground however after his death the old
man smiles and claps for him in
appreciation just then kumi's hands are
untied she smiles while looking at her
husband's body clearly delighted with
what just happened more surprisingly the
man who died in the first round dr
tomoda the nurse and everyone else that
akira met during the game arrives at the
arena while clapping for him then akira
gets up from the floor confused as to
why he isn't feeling any pain it turns
out that the knife he was stabbed with
was fake it is then revealed that the
game was a trick to get akira out of his
depressive episode and make him play
chess again he has been in a worse
mental condition since losing the last
match with super blue so to help him get
better this crowd of people traumatized
him for life
the doctor with kumi and the old man
orchestrated the entire game as a part
of shock therapy the old man is actually
the inventor of super blue he wasn't
happy that his creation had made a great
chess player like akira stop playing so
to make up for his mistake he organized
and funded the game this entire time
akira was playing with super blue who
had been passing answers to the old man
through his earpiece the man reveals
that the computer couldn't comprehend
akira's self-sacrificing move because of
which it has malfunctioned meaning that
he has finally won a game against the
super blue the movie ends as akira and
his wife hug while everyone else claps
for them subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out
thank you for watching